[Music]
I think I broke something what my back I
think we've gotta start over don't you I
am about to tell you sounds crazy but
you have to listen I have been stabbed
shot poisoned Rosen Oh electrocuted and
burn oh really
every morning I wake up without a
scratch on me not a dent an offender
I am anymore I have been stabbed shot
poisoned Oh electrocute oh really
every morning I wake up without a
scratch on me not a dent in the fender
Miami more hair something so familiar
about do you ever have data am i die
within five minutes of landing on that
beach along with every other soldier
watch out for that first step you see I
have been stabbed shot poisoned and
frozen oh I am anymore
parasite so for me about every occasion
if I die within five minutes maybe just
another step in the cycle of life come
find me when you wake up
mess with me four chapters what day is
this for you
Judgment Day heaven any of you met me
before it's out of 19 examples yes your
name is NaN Salas came over your flower
when she was a baby
Skinner this is Gus he hates his life
here which is then the name Grinch
how many times have we been here
how many times
it's been an eternity again again again
again
every time you die you get smarter
I hate I think I broke something I think
we better start over don't you
I am about to tell you it sounds crazy
but you have to listen to me